since the start of the coronavirus
shutdowns in March more than 40 million
Americans have filed for unemployment
benefits but we may be turning a corner
New York City the country's epicenter of
the outbreak announced the first steps
for reopening our lead national
correspondent David beg no reports from
lower Manhattan we think a minimum of
200,000 New Yorkers will be coming back
to work that's the mayor of New York
City Bill de Blasio saying yesterday
that the first phase of reopening the
city could begin as early as next week
what's phase one construction
manufacturing wholesale and retail but
only with things like curbside pickup
not included the city's 27,000
restaurants which has left some business
owners frustrated meanwhile New York's
Governor Andrew Cuomo promised to sign
an executive order that will allow
business owners to deny entry to anyone
not wearing a mask that store owner has
a right to protect themselves but you
have some businesses around the country
that are taking the opposite approach
like the Liberty Tree Tavern in Elgin
Texas there's a sign on the door that
says if people feel that they need to
wear a mask they should stay home until
they feel that it's safe
24 states reported increases in their
average new kovat 19 cases compared to
two weeks ago including Alabama which
has more than 5,000 new positive cases
of coronavirus in the last 14 days and
in Missouri where crowds of people went
to a Memorial Day pool party at Lake of
the Ozarks we're hearing from one of
those participants his name is Antoine
we had a bowl not gonna lie but when we
got back is when everything started he's
a forklift operator from Troy Missouri
who asked us not to use his last name or
reveal where he works people at the
party were seen crowding together many
of them not wearing masks
he says he brought one but he admits he
wasn't always wearing it and now antoine
says he's been asked by his employer to
stay away from work and quarantine for
14 days without pay I wasn't to
everybody this is definitely gonna put a
hit on my bills if I would have known
before I had gone to this party that I
was gonna come back to 14 days no pay no
way I woulda did it that just sounds
stupid on my part for going if you're
surprised to hear that Antoine's company
isn't paying him Antoine says he talked
to an attorney who said hey listen you
either need to get a test result and
then maybe the company will pay you
Anton said he tried that but the company
but the testing company said we're not
gonna test you for now because you have
no symptoms or the attorney told Antoine
listen you need to get a doctor's note
approving you to go back to work Antoine
said he called his doctor and the doctor
said hey that's on you we're not writing
you a note you went to that party and
took that risk Tony you can imagine how
cases like this might wind up in the
court as companies say to employees stay
home and we're not gonna pay you know
you're absolutely right David that's a
great report and a great reminder as
well thank you very much